[Musik]
danke Susanne Daubner wir greifen das
gleich auf die Tagesschau hat gerade
ausführlich berichtet über die
sogenannte zweite Phase der
militärischen Gegenreaktionen der
Israelis auf die Terrorakte vom 7
Oktober vor allem wollen wir aber auf
uns blicken auf unsere Politik auf
unsere Gesellschaft denn auch das Leben
und Politik in der Bundesrepublik haben
sich in diesen drei Wochen grundlegend
verändert der Bundeskanzler die
Regierung die Fraktionen haben immer
wieder Solidarität mit Israel erklärt es
gibt auch viele Kundgebungen bei denen
das bekräftigt wird das öffentliche Bild
ist aber bestimmt von
proalästinensischen Demonstrationen bei
denen Gewalt und Terror bejubelt werden
die immer wieder zur Gewalt aufrufen und
gewalttätig werden Zentrum der
Auseinandersetzungen ist meist Berlin
mit hunderten Festnahmen in den letzten
Wochen mit über 100 Verletzten
Polizistinnen und Polizisten begleitet
ist das Ganze von einer neuen Welle von
Antisemitismus die nicht nur erschreckt
ist die auch den Eindruck erweckt dass
Staat und Behörden unvorbereitet und oft
hilflos sind unser Thema jetzt im
Presseclub Krieg und Terror in Nahost
Hass und Angst in Deutschland und ich
freue mich auf diese Runde Ronen Steinke
ist bei uns von der Süddeutschen Zeitung
dort rechtspolitischer Korrespondent
herzlich willkommen ich freue mich auf
Burak jilmas Autor und Publizist der in
Duisburg lebt herzlich willkommen
Theresa weiß Redakteurin in der rehein
meain Redaktion der Frankfurter
Allgemeinen Zeitung sie berichtet dort
über soziales auch häufig über jüdisches
Leben in der Region und herzlich
willkommen Christin Hellberg
narostexpertin freie Journalistin und
viele Jahre Berichterstatterin für die
ARD für die Radios der ARD aus der
Region Frau Hellberg m die Bilder aus
der Tagesschau sind bedrückend die lösen
wieder etwas aus die sogenannte zweite
Phase wie ordnen Sie das Ganze ein wo
stehen wir da gerade ich denke die
israelische Regierung hat zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt einfach fest vor im
Gazastreifen noch Fakten zu schaffen und
die militärische Infrastruktur der
hammas zu zerstören das hat sie
angekündigt das ist auch ihr gutes Recht
das ist das Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
des jüdischen Staates angesichts dieser
furchtbaren barbarischen Terrorangriffe
vom 7 Oktober andererseits sehen wir
dass es für die Menschen in Palästina
und in den in dem Gazastreifen natürlich
selbst sich sehr stark anfühlt wie eine
kollektive Bestrafung das ist ist der
Vorwurf vieler Länder und vieler
Menschen außerhalb Israels und
palästiners die das auch so betrachten
und wir sehen eben auch kritische
Stimmen innerhalb Israels die wir auch
hören müssen wo Menschen ganz klar sagen
also diese getöteten Zivilisten auf
unserer Seite kann man nicht einfach
jetzt benutzen um auf der anderen Seite
auch Zivilisten zu töten vor allem eben
auch Kinder die sehr stark sterben und
eigentlich was ich mich tatsächlich
Frage ist wie können wir denn Hamas als
Organisation zerschlagen und wirklich
zerstören ist eine rein militärische
Lösung möglich und das würde ich
verneinen ich denke nicht dass wir mit
militärischen Mitteln eine
Terrororganisation wie die Hammer ist
wirklich zerst hören können da braucht
es etwas anderes eine Perspektive für
die Palästinenser auch ein Ende der
Besatzung das sind auch Dinge die wir
aus dem Militär von Reservisten von
ehemaligen militärsen Geheimdienstchefs
und das sind auch Stimmen die jetzt
gerade gehört werden müssen in der
abwegung Herr jelmas was sind ihre
Eindrücke und Gedanken angesichts der
Bilder und Nachrichten also bei mir ja
ist das Gefühl der Angst sehr groß das
Gefühl der Verunsicherung sehr groß m
wenn ich mir anschaue dass oder die die
Angst habe dass sich dieser Konflikt
weiterhin dramatisiert und sehr viele
zivile Opfer
fordert auch natürlich mit dem Auge was
wir hier in in Deutschland so als als
Reaktion erleben werden und ich glaube
dass auch so eine große Ohnmacht
irgendwie glaube ich auch bei vielen
gerade da ist so eine große
Sprachlosigkeit und da frage ich mich
wirklich ja wie wie dieser Konflikt
jetzt weitergehen
wird und natürlich ist es vielleicht
naiv zu glauben oder utopisch zu glauben
dass man das irgendwie schnell lös kann
ich habe halt eher das Gefühl dass es
dramatischer wird und habe eher gerade
große Fragezeichen Anstalt halt
irgendwie ganz klare Antworten auf die
ganze Sachen Frau weiß wie ordnen Sie
diese sogenannte zweite Phase ein also
es ist natürlich so dass die
Bodenoffensive auf palästinensischer
Seite sehr viele Opfer fordert und das
ist schrecklich aber ich finde wir
müssen auch immer mitnennen dass das
eine Reaktion ist auf den Terror der
Hamas und dass wir Israel zugestehen
müssen sich da auch zu verteidigen und
das Kriegsziel die Hamas zu zerschlagen
ist denke ich ein nachvollziehbares wir
können glaube ich nicht
Israel dazu bringen zum Status quoante
zurückzukehren würde jetzt das was z.B
guterisch gefordert hat also
Waffenstillstand sofort und Zurückgabe
der
Geiseln durchgesetzt werden
dann würde die Hamas immer noch im gaz
herrschen und ich glaube das ist für
Israel nach den Ereignissen des 7
Oktobers nicht hinnehmbar wie ist ihre
Einschätzung Herr stankke zweite Phase
klingt so m dass man nicht weiß ob es
Anfang Mitte oder Ende einer Entwicklung
ist al ist auf jeden Fall schrecklich
für die Menschen wenn man die Bilder
sieht israel hat das Recht und auch die
Pflicht sich zu verteidigen das bedeutet
den Angriff der Hamas zu beenden
dauerhaft das heißt auch die Geiseln
zurückzuholen das ist vom Völkerrecht
sozusagen der eine Befehl und
gleichzeitig gibt den Befehl des
Völkerrechts dabei Zivilisten zu schonen
und zu schützen
so und das erzeugt ein Dilemma wenn sich
die Hamas seit Jahren verschanzt in
zivilen Gebäuden sich tarrend also keine
Uniform trägt bewusst versucht zu
verschmelzen mit einer zivilen
Bevölkerung es darauf anlegt dass den
militärischen Gegner es fast unmöglich
gemacht wird zu differenzieren zwischen
Kombattanten einerseits und Zivilisten
andererseits das hat sich Israel nicht
ausgesucht das könnte die Hamas auch
abstellen die könnte anfangen sich wie
eine reguläre Armee zu benehmen sie ins
Völkerrecht zu halten und das Israel in
diesem Dilemma ist darunter leiden die
Menschen in Gaza warum wühlt uns dieser
Krieg so auf würde auch mal sagen mehr
auf als andere schreckliche Kriege
Auseinandersetzung Ereignissen die wir
in den letzten Jahren erlebt haben uns
hier in
Deutschland also erstmal gut es erstmal
menschlich sehr begrüßenswert wenn uns
so etwas auffühlt und nicht kalt lässt
gleichzeitig haben wir natürlich viele
von uns in unserer vielfältigen
Gesellschaft auch persönliche
Beziehungen auf die eine oder andere
Weise und die Beziehung zwischen Staat
Deutschland und Staat Israel sind auch
historisch äh durch Schuld und durch den
Holocaust besondere allein deswegen ist
es richtig da besonders sorgfältig
hinzuschauen und nichts verkehrt ist ich
denke viele Menschen sehen sich vor dem
Dilemma dass sie das Gefühl haben sie
müssten sich entscheiden sie müssen
jetzt entweder für Israel Partei
ergreifen oder auch das palästinensische
Leid benennen und das frustriert viele
Menschen in Deutschland und ich erleb
das so dass eigentlich die Menschen sich
wünschen würden dass man das alles
benennen kann und auch solidarisch sein
kann also das Leid der Palästinenser
benennen offiziell sie sind gleich
wieder dran ich will mal eben
Bundeskanzler Scholz zu Wort kommen
lassen weil sie sagen viele Leute haben
das Gefühl man müsse sich entscheiden
die Bundesregierung der Bundeskanzler
hat sich entschieden Donnerstag in
Brüssel Israel ist ein demokratischer
Staat mit sehr humanitären Prinzipien
die ihn leiten und deshalb kann man
sicher sein dass die israelische Armee
auch bei dem was sie macht die Regeln
beachten wird die sich aus dem
Völkerrecht ergeben da habe ich keinen
Zweifel das ist glaube ich der Impuls
gerade deutscher Politiker durch alle
Parteien hinweg die wir auch gesehen
haben dass der Anspruch dass sich die
israelische Armee an das Völkerrecht
hält und Verhältnismäßigkeit wart
natürlich gar nicht sich stellt weil das
ein demokratischer Rechtsstaat ist ne
undun kann man aber natürlich schon
diese israelische Regierung kritisieren
für das was sie auch in der letzten Zeit
gemacht hat es gibt ja innerhalb Israels
sehr viel Kritik Kritik auch an der
Regierung Netanyahu der jetzt nachgesagt
wird dass sie die Hauptverantwortung
auch für diesen Terrorangriff trägt weil
sie die Prioritäten falsch gesetzt habe
weil man eben das besiedeln des
jordanlandes ganz oben angestellt hat
weil Teile der Armee in den ins
Westjordanland abgezogen wurden um dort
auch radikal auftretende Siedler zu
schützen und weil man den hamasterror
der aus Gaza womöglich kommt nicht
richtig gesehen hat in dieser Regierung
sitzen Menschen die offen werben für
eine Annektion des Westjordanlandes da
sitzen Menschen die ja auch wie im Falle
des Minister des Ministers für nationale
Sicherheit die mal verurteilt wurden
wegen Mitgliedschaft in einer
Terrororganisation in den 1990er Jahren
und wir haben ja durchaus in den letzten
Monaten auch Kritik gehört an dieser
Regierung die nun mit einemal
weggewischt ist weil man in diesen
aufgeheizten Zeiten sich einfach hinter
diese Regierung stellt und ich würde
eben plädieren noch ganz kurz zum
Abschluss dass deutsche staatsrisant
sich eben vor allem definieren sollte an
Solidarität mit den Menschen in Israel
und nicht automatisch mit einer
israelischen Regierung der jetzt
vorgeworfen wird im Land selbst durch
Israelis dass sie eben die Sicherheit
der Menschen nicht als oberste Priorität
verfolgt hat Frau weer JAL ja also ich
finde es ist natürlich vollkommen
richtig dass man israelische politische
Entscheidungen kritisieren darf wir
müssen aber irre aufpassen dass wir da
nicht abbiegen in ein Diskussion oder
eben eine Kritik die dann sofort so
umfassen wird dass sie das Existenzrecht
Israels in Frage stellt und das passiert
aber sehr häufig es wird dann nämlich
eigentlich gefragt ja unter welchen
Bedingungen darf denn dieser stat
existieren unter welchen welche
politischen Entscheidung darf er denn
treffen um noch ein Existenzrecht zu
haben ich da würde ich aufpassen
natürlich haben sie recht das stimmt
meine Bekannten in Israel erzählen mir
auch sie sind sehr unzufrieden mit der
damit wie die politische Lage gehändelt
wird trotzdem wollte ich noch mal klar
machen es ist wichtig dass wir da nicht
falsch abbiegen mhm Herm also ich glaube
dass ähm wenn wir über Kritik sprechen
ähm ist es natürlich gerade in
Kriegszeiten wichtig die Frage ist halt
eben nur wie und zu welchem Anlass und
ähm mache ich z.B auch diese kriegs- und
kampfretorik mit ich erlebe seit dem 7
Oktober seit dem Anschlag seit dem
Terroranschlag der Hamas wirklich so ein
Kampf um Bilder und ein Kampf um Deutung
und gerade in diesem Kampf um Deutung
merke ich dass
ähm Menschen dann häufig dazu kippen
diesen Terror dann auch zu verhamlosen
oder zu relativieren und zu vergleichen
und den deutungsraum soweit zu eröffnen
dass sie sagen ja wir müssen uns jetzt
mit
1967 auseinandersetzen oder mit 48 oder
mit vor 2000 Jahren und da kommen wir
halt in einen ein ein System wo wir die
ganze Zeit Gewalt aufrechnen und ich
frage mich wie wir halt in diesen
Diskussion Weiterkommen konnen weil
dieses aufrechnen ist leider ein
Klassiker in diesem Konflikt das hört ja
gar nicht mehr auf und vor allem merke
ich dann auch und das ist so das was ich
dann auch so häufig so mitkriege dass
man den 7 dass man den Terror am 7
Oktober zu einer Art von Reaktion
erklärt so nach dem Motto wie reagieren
hier auf Ungerechtigkeit anstatt sich
damit auseinanderzusetzen dass da eine
Überzeugung dahinter ist dass da eine
Ideologie dahinter ist und ich glaube
wenn jetzt diese deutungsräume überall
aufgemacht werden dass man halt sich auf
die Reaktion fokussiert anstatt auf die
Überzeugung und sich halt eben genau
damit auseinanderzusetzen her Steinke
wie weit geht die staatsreson und wie
weit geht die Möglichkeit Israel zu
kritisieren is kritisieren muss man
unbedingt können also in den Nachrichten
könzlich war zu sehen dass sich Menschen
in Gaza Ihren Namen mit Filzstift auf
den Arm schreiben weil sie davon
ausgehen wenn sie sterben dann werden
sie zumindest identifizierbar sein und
mit ihren Familienmitgliedern beerdigt
werden und Eltern schreiben ihren
Kindern den Namen auf den Armen mit
filstift man kann sich gar nicht
vorstellen was an einem Vater einer
Mutter vorgehen muss um soweit zu sein
also natürlich muss man da auch als
Weltgemeinschaft und auch als Freund
Israels kritisch gucken ob da sich immer
an alles gehalten wird und ob da
überzogen wird und ich glaube das tun
die Israelis am allerschärfsten am
allerkritischsten und ich habe auch
nicht den Eindruck ehrlichag staatsreson
ist so ein großes Wort ja von Angela
Merkel in die Welt gesetzt und seitdem
weitergetragen ich habe nicht den einru
das so brachial sozusagen als ja und
amen Doktrinen gelebt wird sondern auch
Angela Merkel war durchaus kritisch zu
netanyu Regierung hat z.B die ja die
Gespräche mit dem israelischen Kabinett
die es oft früher gab dann irgendwann
eingefrorenen ausgesetzt die
nachfolgerregierung ist auch eine die
Distanz pflegt und zwar zurecht zur
israelischen Regierung ja zur neuen
israelischen Regierung erst recht was
die Siedlungspolitik betrifft was die
Besatzungspolitik betrifft also ich habe
eigentlich keinen Grund zu kritisieren
dass man da in Deutschland sozusagen zu
einseitig ist ich habe eigentlich den
Eindruck auch Olaf Scholz ist durchaus
differenziert letzten Tage zu hören
gewesen sie sind weiß nicht ob der
einzige Jurist am Tisch aber sie sind
Jurist am Tisch und sie berichten als
rechtspolitischer Korrespondent
wir haben ja bei den Demonstrationen die
gerade stattfinden sehr konkret die
Frage wie weit man gehen darf wie weit
das Recht ich lass die Gewalttaten mal
außen vor aber wie weit das Recht der
öffentlichen Äußerung der Versammlung
der Demonstration geht also wo ist da
die Grenze was darf man über den
Konflikt und über Israel fordern sagen
tun und was ist gesetzlich nicht möglich
also insgesamt Demonstration zu
verbieten ist eine Demokratie sowie
Zeitungen zu verbieten das sollte man
ganz ganz zurückhaltend in absoluten
Extremfällen nur tun und nicht schon
desweg passiert aber gerade es gibt in
Berlin aber nur deswegen weil man da
Straftaten befürchtet nicht deswegen
weil man da Meinungen äh befürchtet die
empörend sind die Weisheit einer
liberalen Ordnung des Grundgesetzes ist
eigentlich zu sagen wenn Meinungen da
sind es ist doch gesünder wir sprechen
uns das ins Gesicht wir machen das bei
Tageslicht als dass man die Leute zwingt
zu Hause zu bleiben und das köcheln
lässt das ist am Ende eher noch
gefährlicher also das ist erstmal in
Ordnung ja vieles werden wir noch drüber
reden was wir empörend finden oder ich
jedenfalls empören finde was man da hört
ist trotzdem nicht dass man es verbieten
sollte aber wenn Leute anfangen sagen
Sie es was empört sie und sollte nicht
verboten werden also ich finde z.B wenn
man
gegen jüdische Gemeinden hier zuande
vorgeht W man vor Synagogen zieht ja
dann ist hat das nichts mit Kritiker in
Israel zu tun dann ist das
Antisemitismus dann verwechselt man da
ein bisschen die Kategorien und dennoch
ist es etwas wo das das
Versammlungsrecht vorsichtig ist und das
Versammlungsrecht sagt also demoruten
und so weiter das ist nicht per se etwas
wo man dann mit Verboten schon gleich
kommen kann aber wenn Leute anfangen mit
Süßigkeiten verteilen mit irgendwelchen
jubelaktion zu zeigen dass sie den den
Verbrechen von einer Terrorgruppe gut
heißen dass sie eigentlich dazu
auffordern man soll noch mehr solche
Verbrechen zeigen da ist eine Grenze
erreicht das ist Billigung von
Straftaten das ist vielleicht auch
Volksverhetzung und da brauchst eine
klare Grenze fr weberg ja
klare Grenze ich denke auch die sollte
gezogen werden in Frankfurt wurde es so
getan in der Vergangenheit in den
letzten Wochen es wurden Demonstrationen
verboten das ist ein total krasser
Schritt das stimmt aber ähm dort war zu
erwarten dass Leute aus dem Umfeld ähm
von samidun dem palästinensischen
Gefangenen Netzwerk und altak Barani
einer
deutschiranischen Aktivisten die
öffentlich äußert beide sind jetzt
Stichworte die das Publikum
wahrscheinlich eher verwirren müssen sie
kurz erklären okay dann erkläre ich kurz
also die Demonstrationen in
Frankfurt sind unter anderem verboten
worden weil befürchtet wurde dass dort
Aussagen getätigt werden die das
Existenzrecht Israels ab sprechen und
die
die Taten der Hamas als legitim
Befreiungskampf Labeln das sind Aussagen
die z.B eit Barani getätigt hat sie war
die Anmelderin der Demonstration
übrigens auch der in Berlin die dann
auch verboten wurde
ich denke wenn solche Aussagen getätigt
werden dann ist eine Grenze
erreicht ich denke wenn wir den Terror
der Hamas eben nicht so wie Herr jemas
das vorhin schon gesagt hat als das auch
begreifen was er ist sondern dann in
dieses auf kommen das kann nicht
funktionieren es gibt etwas was ich
nicht höre was ich also man kann auch
empören durchschweigen muss ich auch
sagen ich frage mich bei diesen Demos
warum höre ich nicht nieder mit Hamas ja
nieder mitamas die dem gaserstreifen
dieses furchtbare Leid eingebockt hat
können wir gleich noch mal können wir
gleich noch mal drauf zurückkommen diese
Seite beleuchten aber ich möchte gerne
verstehen was von dem was wir gerade
erleben ist
illegitimer wütender
gesetzüberschreitender Protest und was
ist Teil dessen was wir als Gesellschaft
aushalten müssen fr hellbergs s der
Demonstration ja auch aufgeladen
emotional aufgeladene Veranstaltungen
und keine konstruktiven Diskurse
Menschen gehen auf die Straße weil sie
wütend sind ich bin ganz bei Frau weiß
zu sagen dass Existenz recht Israels ist
die rote Linie in Deutschland das kann
ich nicht in Frage stellen macht das ein
Palästinenser der mit seiner Flagge
demonstrieren geht der sich diese diesen
Schal umbindet das sind natürlich ganz
normale Symbole der Solidarität mit
Palästina und ich denke viele Menschen
auch im Neuköln und in also den
Stadtteil in Berlin angesprochen haben
das Gefühl dass all das schon von vorne
rein verboten wird in der Angst es
könnten solche Äußerungen getätigt
werden dann haben wir diese
palästinensische Flagge mit den Umrissen
Israels wo man dann unterstellen kann
das bedeutet die Auslöschung des
israelischen Staates wir haben diesen
Schlachtruf free palästine eine
Befreiung Palästinas zu fordern kann
erstmal bedeuten dass die Besatzung
enden soll sie kann bedeuten dass man
sich von der Hamas befreien möchte das
muss nicht zwangsläufig bedeuten dass
sich Israel das Existenz rcht abspreche
aber was ich mit großer Sorge beobachte
ist dass ich eben junge Menschen
insbesondere entfremden auch von diesem
Staat weil die Polizei auch in Berlin
zumindest sehr unklug vorgegangen ist
indem man wirklich jede kleine
Solidaritätsbekundung jede Mahnwache
jede palästinensische Fahne sofort
unterbunden hat jedes wurde ja eine
Israelin die mit einem Schild auf der
sonnenal stand eine israelische
Staatsbürgerin die gegen Besatzung und
vorgegangen ist die wurde dann auch
gleich verhaftet und das ist glaube ich
nicht
zielführend ich kann da vielleicht
berichten von vielen Gesprächen mit
palästinensischen Jugendlichen die ich
in den letzten Tagen und Wochen hatte
die übrigens auch den Terror der Hammers
verhamlosen und z.B dann sagen wir haben
in der Schule nicht die Möglichkeit
darüber zu sprechen in der
Öffentlichkeit bei den Demos wollen wir
eigentlich auch nicht so wirklich mit
dabei sein weil da Leute mitlaufen mit
denen wir nichts zu tun haben wollen und
wir haben aber betroffene Familie in
Gaza wo sollen wir unsere Trauer
ausdrücken und ich finde das ist ein
absolute das ist eine absol absolut
berechtigte Frage und wir müssen auch
m auch aus der muslimischen Perspektive
gesprochen Antwort darauf finden wie
kann man dieses Thema
auf die Straßen bringen in die
Öffentlichkeit bringen ohne dass wir
wissen dass da antisemitische Sachen
gesagt werden dass da zur Vernichtung
von Israel aufgerufen wird und ich
glaube das ist halt eben genau die
Grenze in diesem Fall die halt eine sehr
starke Rolle spielt weil ich komme aus
Duisburg wir hatten 2009 eine Demo die
wurde als proalästinensisch angemeldet
und die ist völlig eskaliert also dieser
Demonstrationszug ist von der Fahne von
der Israel Fahne stehene geblieben Leute
haben Steine auf das Gebäude geworfen
wollten das wirklich anzünden also
alleine beim bei der Besichtigung dieser
Fahne sind da so viele Emotionen
ausgebrochen und dann ist die Polizei in
das Gebäude gestürmt hat die Fahne
runtergenommen und der Mob unten hat
gejubelt und übelste antisemitische
Sachen von sich gesagt und da müssen wir
halt auch wirklich in in den ehrlichen
Diskurs reingehen und Fragen
okay ist das wirklich noch Solidarität
oder geht da vielleicht vielleicht um
was ganz anderes und ich glaube dass wir
gerade mit den Menschen die vielleicht
eine gute Absicht haben auf den Demos
dass wir uns fragen müssen wie können
wir den Angebot machen aber gleichzeitig
eine ganz klare Grenze zu denen ziehen
die das eigentlich nur für sich
instrumentalisieren wollen wie
gefährlich wie explosiv ist die Lage
denn also verfassungsschutzchef Thomas
Haldenwang sagt es sein 1800 Straftaten
in dem Zusammenhang in der
Bundesrepublik in letzten drei Wochen
registriert worden
gut ich meine hier leben Millionen
Menschen es sind hunderte manchmal ein
paar tausend die auf der Straße sind
haben wir es mit einer Entwicklung zu
tun die die uns die unsere Gesellschaft
die den gesellschaftlichen Frieden
bedroht oder mit etwas was wir jetzt
einfach aushalten müssen ja massiv also
jüdische Einrichtungen sind ohnehin in
einem Belagerungszustand muss man glaub
dazu sagen also auch wenn nicht gerade
im Nahost die Situation hochköchelt sind
jüdische Schulen von der Polizei bewacht
ist es nicht möglich eine Synagoge zu
besuchen in Deutschland ohne durch ein
Metalldetektor zu gehen ja nicht
deswegen weil es die Gemeindemitglieder
sich so wünschen dass die Polizei sagt
das ist die gefahrstufe die wir haben
und das ist Alltag und jetzt kommt noch
mal oben drauf diese Eskalation ja da
kommen noch mal zusätzlich extra
bewaffnete Leute also das jüdische
Schulen sind leer teilweise ja an dem
Freitag wo die Hamas weltweit zum Tag
des Zorns aufgerufen hat haben viele
jüdische Eltern ja die Entscheidung
getroffen nicht ihre Kinder in die
Schule zu schicken 80% der Eltern der
jüdischen Schule in Frankfurt hab ber
ähnlich also das ist massiv
und alle an ich finde es auch
unerträglich wenn wir meine Bekannten
erzählen sie traut sich nicht mehr mit
ihren Kindern Hebräisch auf der Straße
zu sprechen das ist nun eine Israelin
die eigentlich sehr kritisch gegenüber
ihre Regierung ist die sich als seäkular
begreift also gar nicht religiös aber
der Hass richtet sich eben gegen alles
was mit diesem Staat in Verbindung
gebracht wird und das ist wahnsinnig
bedenklich und das macht mir auch große
Angst aber da müssen wir uns jetzt
fragen wie können wir Brücken schlagen
wie können wir es gemeinsam schaffen
Antisemitismus effektiv lassen sie uns
erstmal fragen wie können wir
kurzfristig damit also ich habe ich habe
bewusst etwas provokativ gefragt weil es
wichtig ist zu differenzieren und es sag
mal legitime
Interessen legitime Äußerungen gibt aber
äh ich glaube die Dramatik führt doch zu
der Frage was können wir kurzfristig tun
um bedrohte Menschen vor allem jüdische
Menschen und Einrichtungen zu schützen
was können wir kurzfristig tun damit es
nicht weiter eskaliert und dann ist die
andere Frage was können wir langfristig
gesellschaftlich tun ich glaube da
geht's erstmal darum dass wir überhaupt
ein Bewusstsein für das Thema entwickeln
weil auch wenn wir gerade eine Hochphase
von antisemitischer Gewalt haben die
Meldestelle RIAS hat jetzt äh vor
wenigen Tagen ein Bericht rausgebracht
dass wir seit dem 7 Oktober über 2000
antisemitische Vorfälle in Deutschland
haben
ähm die halt das Leben
und auch die Sicherheit der deutschen
Jüdinnen und Juden hier bedroht weil
Menschen einfach sich diesen Konflikt
anschauen und die Menschen hier vor Ort
dafür verantwortlich machen und ich
erlebe immer noch dass dieses Problem
weiterhin verhamlost wird dass weiterhin
gesagt wird ja die Leute sind halt ein
bisschen emotional und sind gerade ein
bisschen sauer und ich merke immer noch
dass dann Problembewusstsein herrscht
und wir müssen in diesem Kontext
natürlich über viele verschiedene Formen
von Antisemitismus sprechen auch z.B den
islamistischen kom noch mal auf meine
Frage zurück also sie haben beschrieben
es brennt und was können wir jetzt
kurzfristig tun um erstmal wieder ein
Gefühl von Frieden und Sicherheit
herzustellen also zunächst mal ist ja
die herrstell oder die Bekämpfung von
Kriminalität Aufgabe des Staates also
Polizei und Staatsanwaltschaft sind
aufgerufen hier klare Kante zu zeigen
das muss man sagen ist in vergangenen
Jahren nicht geschehen obwohl ich dazu
sagen möchte dass es jetzt in den
letzten Wochen versuche gibt da sich
anders zu verhalten z.B in Hessen ist es
so dass die Generalstaatsanwaltschaft
per Rundverfügung die
Staatsanwaltschaften aufgefordert hat
antisemitische Straftaten besonders
schnell und priorisiert zu verfolgen
trotzdem das muss man sich kritisch
anschauen also 2018 als es schon mal ein
gasakrieg gab 49 Tage lang furchtbar da
2014 Verzeihung da gab es in Berlin
Schlachtrufe auf der größ Prachtstraße
Kurfürsten Damm wo Leute gerufen haben
Hamas Hamas Juden ins Gas so
Staatsanwaltschaft hat nichts gemacht
oder Jude Jude feiges Schwein komm raus
und kämpf allein auf deutschen Straßen
wird sowas skandiert und hat die
Staatsanwaltschaft sich rausgeredet na
ja das se ja mehrdeutig Jude Jude das
können auch israelische Militär gemeint
sein also ich glaube da ist die Kritik
schon an der richtigen Adresse und da
muss die müssen die
straverfolgungsbehörden schon sich auch
nicht so sehr für dumm verkaufen lassen
wie es in vergangenen Jahren geschehen
ist das stimmt natürlich da sind wir
auch genau bei einem Kernproblem das
nämlich
der Konflikt zwischen Israel und der
Hamas der jetzt auch gerade eben wieder
schrecklich
hochkocht dass der übertragen wird dass
der überschwabt hierher und es eine
Übertragung gibt der Verantwortung für
irgendwelche politischen militärischen
Entscheidung von Israel auf deutsche
Juden das kann nicht sein das ist ein
Problem und das äußert sich dann in der
Art wie wir es jetzt schon besprochen
haben was kann man kurzfristig tun ich
bin absolut bei Herrn Steinke dass der
Staat das ist staatsaufgab ist da jetzt
für Sicherheit zu sorgen es ist so dass
sich die Lage in Deutschland sehr
unterschiedlich gestaltet z.B in
Frankfurt hat die Polizei bei den
proalästinensischen ich ma mal so weil
das zum Teil eher prohamas
Demonstrationen waren oder
Kundgebungen sehr bemüht gezeigt sofort
alles zu unterbinden es wurde es gab
sofort Festnahmen und man hatte das dort
ganz gut im Griff die Situation ist in
Berlin aber eine vollkommen andere und
das liegt auch an dem
großen Potential der großen Menge von
Menschen die das muss man halt so sagen
sich durch tiktok Instagram und so
weiter von Hamas direkt beeinflussen
lassen die Hamas schafft es in
Deutschland dass innerhalb von 20
Minuten tausende Männer in Berlin auf
die Straße gehen z.B nach dem Angriff
auf das Krankenhaus mm und dagegen denke
ich sollten wir auch Bildung und
Präventionsprogramme auflegen
das ist jetzt wieder geht schon Richtung
langfrist aber deshalb Herr jas ähm wer
sind diese Demonstranten wo kommen sie
her wie lange leben Sie bei uns wie
viele äh sind hier zu Hause wie viele
sind in letzter Zeit eingewandert welche
Wurzeln haben sie ich glaube das ist ähm
sehr unterschiedlich also wir haben
Jugendliche dort deren Familien seit
zwei bis drei Generationen ähm hier
leben wir haben Menschen dort die ähm ja
relativ neu hier sind ähm als alle einen
palästinensischen oder arabischen oder
muslimischen Hintergrund zum großen Teil
schon also zum großen Teil ist es
wür würden wir schon genau über diese
über diese Gruppen sprechen
und diese Mobilisierung die Sie gerade
angesprochen haben das ist nämlich halt
auch das entscheidende z.B in den
sozialen Medien haben wir sehr viele
influencer und Youtuber die halt durch
diesen Konflikt ihre Reichweite ausbauen
indem die einfach massive
emotionalisierende Videos machen und
auch noch mal gleichzeitig den Druck auf
diese Menschen ausüben indem sie sich
z.B vors Brandenburger Tor stellen
ein tiktok Live Video machen und sagen
wenn ihr Muslime seid dann kommt ihr
jetzt sofort hierhin also man versucht
auch gleichzeitig die Deutungshoheit vom
Islam zu Kern und auch Druck in die
Community auszuüben nach dem Motto wenn
ihr nicht mitlaufen wollt hier dann seid
ihr Verräter und das ist halt etwas was
gerade innerhalb der Community gerade
eine Rolle spielt weil viele halt auch
diesem Druck halt ausgesetzt sind und äh
Menschen sich dann auch vielleicht nicht
trauen irgendwie eine gegenhaltung zu
zeigen und da merke ich dass wir da halt
einfach eine klare Grenze zeigen müssen
also ich frage mich warum kann tiktok
oder Instagram warum können Sie nicht
Videos löschen wo zu Vernichtung
aufgerufen wird also da muss in den
Unternehmen selber eigentlich ganz
vieles getan werden okay also wir haben
sozusagen das die Frage in welchem Stil
geht die Polizei praktisch vor wir haben
das Problem der sozialen Netzwerke die
da als
mobilisierungsinstrument gebraucht
werden freberg die politische Debatte
ist ja schnell das Gefühl ist warum sind
die diese Menschen in Anführungszeichen
einfach bei uns der SPD Vorsitzende Lars
klingball sagt wer antisemitisch ist hat
bei uns keine Bleibeperspektive
inwiefern ist also das Thema ausweisen
abschieben ein Element der Debatte ich
glaube dass diese Forderung nach
Ausweisung oder der Aberkennung von
Staatsangehörigkeit viel zu kurz greift
ehrlich gesagt sind ja auch nur sehr
wenige Menschen davon betroffen also
doppelstatler die man jetzt eine
Staatsangehörigkeit aberkennen könnte
das ist ein sehr gefährliches Fahrwasser
auch juristisch sehr kompliziert
umzusetzen da müssen wir glaube ich
vorsichtig sein und das löst ja nicht
das Grundproblem dass sich weite Teile
der migrantischen Gesellschaft hier also
hier lebende Muslime die aus Palästina
wutzeln haben oder auch aus Syrien nicht
gesehen fühlen in diesem Konflikt und
diese hassbutschaften auf eine Gefühls
auf ein Gefühlszustand prallen wo diese
Menschen eben sagen das ist alles
einseitig israel kann seit Jahrzehnten
machen was es will es kann
palästinensisches Land beschlagnahmen
meine Verwandten werden jetzt in Gaza
bombardiert also diese persönliche
Verstrickung in den Nahostkonflikt wird
zu wenig in Rechnung gestellt und ich
denke was wir dringend brauchen ist eine
Form von
Erinnerungskultur in Deutschland an
diesen Holocaust der anschlussfähig ist
in einer makrantischen Gesellschaft also
wir müssen die Leute abholen wir müssen
dafür sorgen dass me Frage zurück Herr
Steinke also wir haben eine Diskussion
über ausweisen abschieben Justizminister
Marko Buschmann sagt wir müssen bei der
Einbürgerung sehr viel zurückhaltender
sein weil ein Teil der genommenen einen
deutschen Pass hat etwa die Hälfte in
Berlin also welche rechtsstaatlichen
Maßnahmen sind an der Stelle realistisch
wirksam wünschenswert also wenn jemand
schon einen deutschen Pass hat
Doppelstaatler kann man den auch den
zweiten Pass nicht einfach ohne weiteres
entziehen da hat das grundgesetetzt
zurecht hohe Hürden übrigens gerade von
dem Hintergrund der deutschen Geschichte
ja wo Juden von den Nazis die
Nationalität aberkannt wurde also das
ist schon sehr sehr eigentlich
unrealistisch die zweite Idee Leute
abzuschieben die hier prekär bislang
Leben Schal einfach daran dass im
Westjordanland im Gazastreifen kein
Partner da ist der das ermöglichen würde
also de facto gibt's dorthin keine
Abschiebungen ist also auch eine eine
Forderung fürs Schaufenster und nicht
für die Realität nach Syrien kann ich
auch aus guten Gründen nicht abschieben
und ein Palästinenser der eine
libanesische Staatsangehörigkeit hat in
den Libanon abzuschieben der womöglich
radikalisiert ist wird dazu führen dass
er sich der hbolla anschließt was habe
ich erreicht also ich kann das Problem
auch nicht auslen aber die Frage ist ja
halt auch inwiefern bekämpfen wir damit
Antisemitismus also ich kann ihn ein
persönliches Beispiel nennen ich lese
auch diese Forderung von Abschiebung für
Menschen die sich antisemitisch
Verhalten und ich als jemand der sich
gegen Antisemitismus engagiert ich habe
nach jedem Interview E-Mails von Leuten
die mich anschreiben und sagen dich
schieben wir als ersten ab also wenn wir
uns antisemitisch Verhalten will man uns
abschieben und wenn wir uns gegen
Antisemitismus engagieren musssen wir
uns das auch anhören und da frage ich
mich was will diese Gesellschaft also
das macht doch irgendwie vorne und
hinten keinen Sinn dass man dann meint
Antisemitismus mit Rassismus zu
bekämpfen ich würde mir wünschen dass
wir eine differenzierte Debatte über das
Thema haben auch auch um die Frage wie
können wir in einer vielfältigen
Gesellschaft vielfältige Form von
Antisemitismus bekämpfen und ich möchte
kein Antisemitismus Ranking indem z.B
einige mich dann fragen ja was ist denn
schlimmer der Deutsche oder der
muslimische Antisemitismus also nach dem
Motto der andere Antisemitismus der ist
nur halb so wild und der andere der ist
ganz grausam also wir müssen doch dazu
kommen jeden Antisemitismus konsequent
zu bekämpfen anstatt halt darauf zu
schauen aus welcher Richtung kommt
dieser kommt dieser Hass Frau weiß ich
beobachte aufmerksam danke für für all
Ihre Rückmeldungen in sozialen
Netzwerken im Gästebuch also das Thema
beschäftigt auch unser Publikum und so
die Frage wer ist eigentlich diese
antisemitische Front hat ja ein paar
neue Facetten bekommen also friders for
future international äh ist mit
Äußerungen aufgefallen also es gibt
einen auffälligen linken oder von von
der Klimabewegung getriebenen Teil davon
ein ganz anderer Aspekt ist der
türkische Präsident erdogan hat sich
über die Hamers als
Befreiungsorganisation geäußert was im
Publikum zu der Frage führt was macht
das mit der türkischen Community bei uns
also wie groß wie breit ist die Gruppe
das muss man ja klären bevor man sagt
wie gehen wir damit um wo setzen wir an
und wie können wir langfristig das
Problem ernsthafter bekämpfen ja also
ich denke wir sehen ganz deutlich in den
vergangenen Wochen einen rasanten
Anstieg von antisemitischen Äußerungen
und auch Straftaten aus dem muslimischen
Milieu es ist aber sehr wichtig dann
zweiten Fakt zu nennen nämlich es dieser
antisemitischen Taten geschehen in einem
Kontext von ohnehin viel tiefwurzelen
Antisemitismus in Deutschland wenn man
in den Verfassungsschutzbericht guckt
dann sieht man dass 80% der Straftaten
gegen Juden aus dem rechtsextremen
milieö kommen dazu kommen jetzt in
letzter Zeit vermehrt die muslimischen
milies und natürlich wie Sie
angesprochen haben auch aus dem
linksextrem Spektrum gibt es Leute die
die sich gegen Juden aussprechen
Verhalten Straftaten begehen und dabei
bleibt es auch nicht es gibt ja auch im
Alltag für Juden sehr sehr viele Momente
wo sie diskriminiert und ja nicht
akzeptiert werden und das kommt dann
auch aus der bürgerlichen Mitte ich will
mal ein kleines Beispiel aus Frankfurt
geben wo z.B eine jüdische Person ein
Objekt mieten wollte und der Vermieter
sagt dann nee sorry ich kann dir das
nicht vermieten weil du bist ja jüdisch
und dann kriege ich Stress und das ist
diese Person würde sicherlich von sich
niemals sagen dass sie ein Judenhasser
ist verhält sich aber reproduzierend bei
diesen
antisemitischen
Taten zurück zu ihrer Frage wer sind
jetzt die Leute die da demonstrieren
aktuell ja sind das viele Migranten mit
muslimischem Hintergrund die beeinflusst
sind vom politischen Islam und das ist
eine radikale Ideologie aber auch linke
und eben auch linke vollkommen richtig
die dann da eine Querfront bilden dazu
auch noch eine Beobachtung aus der
jüdischen Gemeinde Frankfurt die
bekommen seit Wochen Mails wie sie sagen
aus der Mitte der deutschen also
dezidiert eben keine Migranten die da
aufspringen und die z.B dann sowas
schreiben wie ja wie könnt ihr Juden
euch das eigentlich rausnehmen
irgendwelche Demonstrationen verbieten
zu wollen da muss man jetzt ganz schnell
einordnen die Juden verbiet keine
Demonstrationen und das bedient den
antisemitischen toppos des jüdischen
Kraken der seine Finger irgendwo drin
hat und alles was was Sie beschreiben
ist dass die Demonstrationen aufscheinen
lassen was Teil dieser wie sie es
genannt haben Querfront ist aber das es
eben viele Wurzeln viele
Anknüpfungspunkte für Antisemitismus
gibt fre ich habe sie eben unterbrochen
sie wollten den Gedanken
nach vorne leiten also eine einfache
Lösung ist bei dieser Problemlage ja
eine Illusion ist eine Illusion
vielleicht ganz kurz noch anschließend
auf das was die Kollegen gesagt haben
also die aktuellen Proteste sind glaube
ich schon von dieser politischen Wut
getrieben gegen den stad Israel den eben
viele Migranten insbesondere
Palästinenserin und Palästinenser als
einen persönlichen Kampf aehen weil sie
eine Biografie haben weil sie eben
keinen naziopa hatten der Juden
vertrieben hat aus Deutschland und
millionenfach getötet hat sondern weil
diese Person eben ein Urgroßvater hat
der vertrieben wurde im Zuge der
Staatsgründung Israels 1948 das heißt
diese Wut die sich aktuell entleht hat
sehr viel zu tun mit der politischen
Lage und nicht unbedingt in einem im
Islam resultierenden Juden hast da gibt
es Verbindungen das ist auf jeden Fall
richtig aber ich denke die aktuelle Lage
ist doch sehr getrieben von diesem
politischen Konflikt und was Herr
Steinke vorhin gesagt hatte würde ich
mich anschließen ich bin sehr enttäuscht
von Linken proalästinensischen milies
die nicht in der Lage sind diesen Terror
der Hamas erstmal eindeutig zu
verurteilen als das was es ist nämlich
Terror und keine Form von Widerstand das
ist keine Form von Widerstand selbst
wenn ich es in einen Kontext wie un
Generalsekretär guteris das getan hat
also zu sagen das hat alles ist ke ist
nicht in ein Vakuum passiert auch das
ist korrekt das hat eine Vorgeschichte
das kann man erklären aber man kann es
nichtklären das ist noch Teil der
Analyse dann sag mal genau die große
Frage Bundespräsident steinmeierer hat
so einen Satz gesagt der so wie viele
politische Sätze erstmal dahin fließt
der mich dann aber doch nachdenklich
gemacht hat also sei genau nicht also
sei nicht nur staatsron sondern Bürger
flicht gegen
Antisemitismus vorzugehen was heißt das
Bürgerpflicht ich finde diesen Satz sehr
wichtig und sehr richtig also den Schutz
jüdischen Lebens in Deutschland zu
Bürgerpflicht zu machen und da muss ich
eben an diese Aufarbeitung und die
Erinnerungskultur in Deutschland gehen
die den Holocaust zum jetzigen Zeitpunkt
vor allem als eine sehr ein sehr
spezifisches deutsches Schuldbekenntnis
definiert also wir haben in den Schulen
im Geschichtsunterricht mehrfach die
Zeit zwischen Weimar Republik und
Zweiten Weltkrieg da ist das passiert
das können wir so erklären das war
furchtbar und das ist ein teil Teil der
deutschen Geschichte deswegen ist es
unsere staatsresort diese Existenz
Israels zu schützen das ist nicht
anschlussfähig für junge Palästinenser
für die der stat Israel eben in erster
Linie mal Vertreibung seiner eigenen
Urgroßeltern und Großeltern bedeutet hat
deswegen müssen wir den Holocaust
versich und ich will weil das
relativiert ihn nicht das ist ja immer
der Vorwurf dass wir irgendwas
relativieren wollen im Gegenteil wir
müssen den Holocaust als ein
Menschheitsverbrechen wahrnehmen als ein
singuläres Menschheitsverbrechen das
Folgen hatte anderswo zu dem man
Anschluss finden kann in den Biografien
solcher Jugendlicher und für dass wir
dann auch universelle
lehrenm Herr Steinke Frau
weiß Kampf zur Bürgerpflicht ich hab
selber mit ich habe damals im
Jugendzentrum als Betreuer gearbeitet
und habe mit vielen Palästinensern zu
diesem Thema auch gearbeitet also ich
habe z.B erstmal ein großen Raum für
Biografiearbeit gemacht und das hat die
Menschen immer abgeholt und diese diese
anerkennende Arbeit die finde ich
erstmal wichtig dann haben wir un z.B
mit der Frage auseinander gesetzt was
ist eigentlich Lokal in Duisburg
passiert was ist in meinem Stadtteil
passiert wenn wir uns die nszeit
anschauen also dass dass ich Biografien
finde wo das ganze sichtbar wird wir
haben Biografien gefunden da haben Leute
aus jüdischen Menschen aus marxl sind
dann erstmal aufgrund von Antisemitismus
nach Duisburg gekommen dann nach
Frankreich von dort aus nach in die USA
dann nach Israel dann ist der Krieg mit
den mit den Arabern ausgebochen von dort
aus in die Ukraine und das sind so
Geschichten die halt persönliche
Geschichten persönlichen persönlichen
Bezug herstellen und wir dürfen auch
nicht vergessen dass wir über den
gegenwärtigen Antisemitismus sprechen
das für mich kritische Erinnerungskultur
bedeutet nicht nur diese Perspektiven
von migrantischen Jugendlichen
mitzunehmen sondern auch kritisch
aufzuarbeiten wenn es um Islamismus und
die z.B die türkische Gewaltgeschichte
geht her stke ich glaube auch in der
linken und fr the future schon
angesprochen worden gibt's ganz stark
verbreitet dieses Bild von David und
Goliat ja die Palästinenser sind die
schwächerin natürlich sind wir auf
Seiten der schwächerin das ist natürlich
nur ein Teil der Wahrheit ja die
Menschen Menschen in Israel sind nicht
dass sie vor Kraft kaum laufen können
und sich in der Sonne gut gehen lassen
sind ihrerseits eine Gesellschaft der
geflüchteten sind Menschen die einhäft
der Gesellschaft sind entweder selber
aus Osteuropa gefloren oder jedenfalls
ihre Vorfahren ja vor
Progromen der scha und auch
antisemittismus nach 45 und die andere
Hälfte der Gesellschaft sind Menschen
die vertrieben wurden aus nahöstlichen
Ländern aus Marokko aus Ägypten wo es
noch Mitte des 20 Jahrhunderts eine
große jüdische Community gab 150 000
Ägypterinnen Ägypter jüdischen Glaubens
sind vertrieben worden mit Gewalt nach
Israel also zu sich vorzustellen in
Israel leben Menschen die aus kolonialem
selbst sozusagen Wunsch nach
Selbsterfüllung dahingehen und sich gut
gehen lassen das ist wirklich da muss
man den Leuten auch mal ein bisschen die
ganze wahit erzähen und dann würde ich
mir wirklich wünschen ich vorhin schon
mal angedeutet dass auf Demos die ich ja
haben will ja wo Menschen ihre
Solidarität mit den palästinenseren
Palästinensern aussprechen das soll ja
dafür soll ja Raum sein dass die auch
den Mut haben zu sagen nieder mit was
oder lass die Geiseln frei was soll das
kleine Kinder in irgendwelchen Keller
verließen in Gaza einzusperren wer hat
da was davon das wünschen sich viele
Menschen weniger Gründe auch für das
israelische Militär da einzumarschieren
und zu schießen dann wäre schon mal ein
Problem weniger fr weiß ein Gedanke von
ihnen kurzer bitte noch zum Schluss sie
haben schon ich glaubeck geschildert ja
ja ich glaube dass es ganz wichtig ist
mit dem Blick auf Deutschland dass wir
hier noch mal differenzieren deutsche
Juden sind nicht Israelis und sie sind
auch nicht verantwortlich für das was da
passiert ich war he dass es emotional
bei den Demonstranten oder auch bei den
Menschen die Straftaten begehen eine
Rolle spielt es kann aber nicht sein
dass deutsche Juden sich für irgendwas
verantwortlich fühlen müssen was anders
wo passiert oder dass sie qua Judentum
in diesen Topf geworfen werden
gleichzetigürenke mich sehr herzlich für
diese Runde
und glaube wir haben zum Schluss
eröffnet wie weit eigentlich der Blick
sein muss wie langfristig die Frage
angelegt sein muss wie Kampf gegen
Antisemitismus zur Bürgerpflicht werden
kann in der ARD jetzt im
europamagazin ein wichtiger Jahrestag
heute 100 Jahre türkische Republik wenn
sie bei phöniix im Netz oder im Radio
dabei sind dann jetzt gleich Presseclub
nachgefragt danke erstmal tschüss und
lassen Sie es gut
[Musik]
gehen und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz im Fernsehen bei
phöniix im Radio bei WDR5 und willkommen
nach Hamburg in die Sendung Klaus
Borchert guten Tag ja schönen guten Tag
in die Runde zwei kurze Sachen vor
etlichen Jahren war einer in dieader ist
ein 11 zjähriger palästinenserjunge von
einer israelischen Kugel getötet worden
und der Vater hat die Organe zu gleichen
Teilen für Palästinenser und jüdische
Kinder freigegeben das nötigt mir
Respekt davon sollte man mal mehr hören
und das zweite was ich total vermisse
auch in der UNO seit 70 Jahren seit fünf
Generationen wird in weiten Bereichen
der Palästinenser der Hass an die Kinder
weitergegeben das geht seit 1948 so das
sind bestimmt 20 30%. so und da kann man
nicht sagen man ist unschuldig wenn man
seine Kinder zum Hass erzieht sorry das
ist NoGo danke Herr ja ja zwei wichtige
Anmerkungen die lassen wir so stehen
vielen Dank für ihre Perspektive und
gehen nach Berlin zu Doris Gert
willkommen im
Presseclub fragat sie haben das Wort
guten Tag mein Name mein Name haben s
ich habe zwei Sachen und zwar ich habe
viele muslimische fre Freunde aber jetzt
habe ich eine Frage wenn ein
Deutscher hitlerfahne verbrennt geht der
viel mehr hat geht ins Gefängnis wenn
man jüdische fahen verbrennt kriegen die
klappchen hier in Berlin auf dem Po und
sagt man das darfst du nicht und dann
die zweite Frage warum tut die Zeitung
nicht mal schreiben dass nicht nur die
Juden
die Ketten vom Hals gerissen kriegen
auch wir Deutschen wir hier werden Leute
verprügelt ja mal zwei
Sachen strinkke geht auf Ihre Fragen
vielen Dank Frau ger also erstmal
jüdische Fahnen ich glaube sie meinen
israelische Flaggen d
ander sagen den Juden wird was angetan
und uns Deutschen auch also ih schon
klar dass es jüdische Deutsche gibt ja
das ist nicht g
das bitte ich glau das ist Teil Problems
dass man Juden als ein Gegenstück zu
deutschen ich muss fast sagen
imaginiert das halte ich eher für etwas
was S noch mal überdenken sollten
Frau vereh nicht vielleicht zur ersten
Frage von Frau ihr Eindruck ist dass
Demonstranten die israelische Flaggen
verbrennen wie sagte sie einen Klaps auf
den Hintern bekommen also Ärger bekommen
das stimmt ja das ist eine Straftat in
Deutschland übrigens wie das Verbrennen
jeglicher Flaggen das ist nicht ein
spezieller Tatbestand der sich nur auf
die israelische Flagge bezieht wer die
deutsche Flagge verbrennt bekommt
dieselbe Strafe fragt danke für Ihren
Blick wir sind in Düsseldorf bei
Reinhard Schneider herr Schneider guten
Tag ja guten Tag und ein Gruß an die
Runde der terroristische Anschlag der
Hammers vom 7.10 hat zweifellos ein
Alleinstellungsmerkmal so dass sich
sogar die una UNO intensiv beschäftigt
hat der Generalsekretär der UNO hat auch
dazu Stellung genommen und auch den Satz
gesagt die Reaktion der Hammers
geschieht nicht im Vakuum es hat eine
erhebliche Empörung weltweit gegeben und
anschließend hat sich guteres auch
empört was hat er denn damit gemeint
und die zweite Frage ist kann
der lassen Sie uns bei der einen Frage
bleiben weil unser Publikum natürlich
jetzt nicht weiß
was g Konflikt auch ein Vietnam
werden das habe ich ja ob der Gaza
Konflikt ein Vietnam werden kann ja das
habe ich jetzt was meinen Sie
damit und zwar ein ein ein Krieg der
sich ein geril Krieg der sich sehr lange
hinzieht ohne dass dieser Konflikt s mal
in Kürze beendet werden kann also dass
wir eine langfristige Lösung für die
Situation in Gaza brauchen das ist
glaube ich auch bei der israelischen
Regierung angekommen das ist ja das was
der US-Präsident beiden auch immer
versucht hat da noch mal hineinzugeben
und die Überlegung ist eben was kann
langfristig aus Gaza werden eine
Rückkehr zu der Situation davor auf
keinen Fall weder aus palästinensischer
Sicht noch aus israelischer Sicht das
ist richtig aber die Frage ist eben
schon es kann keine militärische Lösung
geben wir brauchen einen effektiven
Antiterrorkampf der auch noch andere
Dinge nämlich den näherboden für den
Terror entzieht weil sonst wird einfach
wieder eine neue Gruppe genau das tun
was die Hamas bisher getan hat es gibt
schon schlimmere Gruppen im Gazastreifen
also den näherboden des Terrors
entziehen bedeutet Perspektiven schaffen
für die palästinensische Bevölkerung in
westjodland und in Gaza also eine
Abriegelung z.B darf sich auch nicht
wiederholen da braucht es irgendeine
Form von gemanagem womöglich unter
internationaler Beteiligung die EU die
UN die USA müssen eine Rolle spielen
eine gemanagete Zone sicher die
Sicherheit bringt für Israel und
Perspektiven für die Palästinenser die
dort leben was hat gut Herr Schneider
herr Schneider lassen Sie uns einfach
dabei belassen ich bedanke mich dass sie
dabei sind wir haben viele Anruferinnen
und Anrufer noch und gehen weiter nach
Berlin zu Alexander schwarz guten Tag
guten
Tag ich habe Frage dieser Konflikt läuft
einmal in dem
historischen Zusammenhang des
nahuskonflikts der leider seit 7inhalb
Jahrzehnten bereits besteht aber
andererseits sehe ich das auch als Teil
der weltweiten Auseinandersetzung
zwischen Diktaturen und
terroristischen Diktatur und Demokratien
westlicher Prägung können wir diesen
unheilvollen Lauf noch stoppen diese
Frage habe ich ja wir haben sie
akustisch äh schwer verstehen können und
äh können Sie es einordnen die große
Gefahr glaube ich ist dieser
Flächenbrand was jetzt auch viel
diskutiert wurde also wie wird sich das
ausweiten wie wird das womöglich die
Region in weiteres Chaos stürzen wir
sehen ja auch schon dass US Truppen in
der Region angegriffen werden
Drohnenangriffe das kommt dann meistens
aus iranischer von der iranischen Seite
also wir haben iranisch unterstützte
Milizen im Irak in Syrien die US-Truppen
angreifen das heißt es kann zu einem
Stellvertreterkrieg werden sehr wohl
aber ich denke es hat keiner ein
Interesse daran abgesehen von der Hamas
die sich natürlich wünscht dass das
ganze ein Flächenbrand wird damit die
palästinensische Sache wieder ganz oben
auf der Tagesordnung endet und dann
womöglich zu einer langfristigen Lösung
gefunden wird aber ich denke dass alle
gerade zum jetz Zeitpunkt versuchen mit
abschränkung mit deutlicher Rhetorik die
jeweils andere Seite davon abzuhalten zu
eskalieren im Südlibanon sehen wir das
die hisbolla muss sich entscheiden bin
ich eine libanesische Partei oder bin
ich ein iranischer Proxy der einfach nur
Israel bekämpfen möchte und ich zum
jetzigen Zeitpunkt sehe ich kein
Interesse dieser beteiligten Akteure
dass das Ganze zu einer direkten
Konfrontation wird noch von anderen
Mächten vielleicht zu diesem Aspekt
dass es hier um einen Kampf gegen
Terrorismus also Demokratien gegen
Terrorismus geht ich denke dass das
schon stimmt dass eben die Angriffe der
hammas in diesem Licht zu werten sind
und dass sie sich auch gegen eine
bestimmte Lebensart nämlich unsere
westliche richten dass da z.B auf dem
Festival in der Wüste
Frauen
ausgestellt vergewaltigt dann auf Videos
in den sozialen auf den sozialen Kanälen
der Hamas ja misshandelt wurden das ist
auch ein Zeichen davon dass sich diese
terroristische Gruppe gegen unsere
Freiheit und Gleichberechtigung
wendet bedanke mich für Ihren Anruf und
wir gehen weiter nach priros zu Loa
Stolte her Stolte
willkommen her Stolte hört uns nicht
dann probieren wir es in Hamburg bei
Peter
Reichard tja wir haben muss ich z sagen
wir haben heute ein
bisschennische Wege mit mit unserer
Telefonanlage weil sie ausgefallen ist
und wir uns gerade ein bisschen anders
behelfen aber ich habe eine Stimme
gehört Herr reicher sind sie das ja ich
bin dran ja dann willkommen bitte sie
haben das wor danke also vorweg erstmal
ich bin für das Existenzrecht Israel und
bezeichne auch das was am 7 Oktober ist
von der Hamas als Terror was ich aber
nicht begreife ist dass man also
Palästinenser die hier leben praktisch
also die
verbittet auf die Straße gehen zu
demonstrieren wenn Sie die Bilder aus
Gaza jetzt sehen also ich habe die
Befürchtung dass dadurch WN also eine
Radikalisierung vielleicht stattfinden
kann die sich dann auch
gegen ja deutsche Behörden nachh richtet
und das macht mir Angst ja ja vielen
Dank also ich muss mich noch mal
entschuldigen ich weiß nicht wie es bei
Ihnen zu Hause ist ich habe eine relativ
schlechte Tonqualität aber das hat
glaube ich mit dem Problem unserer
Anlage zu tun ich kann vielleicht
tröstend sagen also sind nicht alleine
mit ihrer Sorge und die Gerichte in
Deutschland in verschiedenen Städten
haben auch bereits deswegen diese
demoverbote aufgehoben also in München
beispielsweise gab es ursprünglich von
der Versammlungsbehörde also läs sich
von der Stadt eine ganz harte Linie
praktisch gar nichts zu erlauben was
irgendwie in Richtung palästiner
Solidarität geht und die Gerichte haben
sie haben das Argument gerade genannt
gesagt nein dafür muss Raum sein und
deswegen wird es jetzt korrigiert und
wir sollten auch nicht pauschal hier
lebende Muslime oder hier lebende
Palästinenser Araber dafür
verantwortlich machen was die Hamas
getan hat wenn einige wenige Süßigkeiten
verteilen und sich freuen heißt es nicht
dass die große Gruppe der hierlebenden
migrantischen Community sich hinter
diesen Terror stellt also dieses
gegenüber kopftuchtragenden Frauen z.B
die fühlen sich auch gerade unter
Generalverdacht das dürfen wir nicht
zulassen sie hatten zuerst Luft geholt
Herr jelmas M zu zu zu Ihrer Frage noch
mal eine eine einen Gedanke
ähm die meisten Palästinenser die hier
in Deutschland geboren und aufgewachsen
sind sind staatenlos
und ich habe häufig wenn ich diese
Familie betreut habe ähm gemerkt dass
sie einfach mit einer Angst aufwachsen
jeden Tag abgeschoben werden zu können
aber die Frage ist halt wohin also dass
wenn wir über über Identität sprechen
auch halt genau diese Perspektive halt
mitdenken müssen um halt da ein Angebot
zu schaffen um vielleicht auch Räume für
diese Ohnmacht zu schaffen für diese für
diese Situation halt zu schaffen und
wenn wir halt irgendwie auch wirklich
langfristig denken wollen dann finde ich
auch wichtig dass wir halt eben
natürlich ensische perspektiv mit in den
Diskurs reinbringen und ich kann ihn
garantieren es gibt etliche da draußen
die nichts mit Terror zu tun haben
nichts mit Hamas zu tun haben und ich
glaube dass dass das in den Diskurs auch
noch mal sehr wichtig sein wird das sind
unsere
Verbündeten bedanke mich herr Reichert
und dann ist Amelie Sanders die nächste
hallo Frau Sanders hallo guten Tag danke
dass ich bei ihn melden darf danke schön
ja schön dass sie angerufen haben danke
danke danke zurück also äh ich beziehe
mich auf eine Sendung im französischen
Fernsehen ich bin halb Französin äh und
eine Sendung ganz ähnlich ihrer die
läuft aber jeden Tag eine hervorragende
sehr neutrale politische Sendung immer
eine Stunde gestern
war natürlich Thema Naos und eine
naosexertin
sagte folgendes
äh immer wird Israel darauf hingewesen
es habe das Völkerrecht einzuhalten
deshal das Kriegsrecht einzuhalten und
dann sagte sie auf
Französisch
F das heißt zu deutsch übersetzt die
Hammers schert sich einen Scheißdreck
drum ums Völkerrecht und ums kriegrecht
Kriegsrecht und das sie zeigen das auch
im französischen Fernsehen dann das
größte Krankenhaus in Gaza City hat
unten drunter eine der Kommandozentralen
von der Hamas aber sagte sie D im franz
Fernsehen wenn jetzt Israel eine Bombe
auf dieses Krankenhaus wfen würde
stellen sich mal vor was dann in der
ganzen Welt los wäre und ein weitere
Gesprächspartner auch eine ausexerte
fügte hinzu es ist Krieg und dass im
Krieg unschuldige Menschen getötet
werden das ist leider leider leider eben
das gehört dazu das ist so und wenn in
Deutschland das füge ich jetzt hinzu am
Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs nicht
sichtausende deutsche Menschen die
unschuldig waren und keine Nazis waren
auch zerbombt worden wären dann wären
wir alle heute
Nazis Punkt wie können die ne Frage dazu
sie brauchen ja eine Frage wie kann man
in Deutschland auch durch die Mächen
etwas dazu beitragen dass man das ein
bisschen
geradet ich denke sie haben vollkommen
recht dass Israel mit doppelten
Standards bewertet wird das ist ein
Problem und ich denke aber dass wir
heute hier in dieser Runde diesen Fehler
nicht begangen haben aber ich halte
nicht ich würd gern Herr steinker einen
Gedanken von Frau Sanders noch
aufgreifen der mir auch durch den Kopf
gegangen ist also auf der einen Seite
haben wir es mit einer terroristischen
Organisation zu tun die ein Gebiet
beherrscht und auf der anderen Seite mit
einem demokratischen Staat und alle
Appelle richten sich in der Tat an den
Staat an Israel internationale
Resolutionen haben Israel im Blick weil
niemand davon ausgeht dass die Hamas auf
Diplomaten hört
m was ja also teilen Sie die
Einschätzung das ist eine sehr
unsymmetrische ja also man sieht es der
UNO Resolution die jetzt erlassen worden
ist also die Herm hat aus ihrer Sicht
aus ihrer perversen Sicht da erstmal ein
erfolgreichen gegen Erstschlag gemacht
die haben geiselnd mit in ihr Gebiet
genommen und erstmal Israel einen großen
Schaden zugefügt und jetzt sagt diese
unoesolution letztlich genau das was die
Hamas sich wünscht nämlich dass sie
jetzt bisschen Ruhe hat ihren Erfolg
feiern kann und dann ganz langsam den
Israelis ihre Bedingungen diktieren kann
unter welchen Sie die Geiseln sozusagen
im Tausch zurückgeben will das der
Appell den jetzt die Mehrheit zumindest
der Staaten in der UN volversammlung
gegeben haben wo Deutschland sich ich
finde feigerweise enthalten hat bei der
Abstimmung einen Hörer
noch wir sind K genau aber wir sind
jetzt bei gundalf Otto in dolfingen
guten Tag her ja dofing guten Tag ich
sehe gewisse Parallelitäten zwischen dem
ukrainisch-russischen Krieg und den
jetzigen
Hamas Terror und mit Israel beide
sprechen die Existenz des jeweiligen
anderen Gegners ab die krultaten haben
sich quasi noch erhärtet vergrößert bei
der Hamas mittlerweile ist auch ein Teil
der iranischen Welt auch
wieder auf der Basis auf der schäne des
Israel nicht mehr existieren soll hat
sich das durch diesen Krieg zwischen
Russland Ukraine irgendwie verstärkt wie
sehen Sie
das hat da jemand noch ein kurzen
Gedanken zu zum Schluss also ich hätte
noch einen kurzen Gedanken um noch mal
daran zu erinnern dass natürlich dass
der Unterschied ist zwischen einer
Terrororganisation und am demokratischen
Rechtsstaat sich ans Völkerrecht zu
halten Terror besteht darin sich genau
an solche Prinzipien nicht zu halten
deswegen ist es keine doppelten Standard
sondern es ist richtig und wichtig
Israel daran zu erinnern als
kriegsführende Parteien auch wenn sie
angegriffen wurden im volögerrecht ist
trotzdem auch der Angegriffene Partner
verpflichtet Verhältnismäßigkeit zu
wahen das Recht auf Selbstverteidigung
geht einher mit dieser
Verhältnismäßigkeit und das ist genau
der Unterschied dass wir das nicht von
Hermas fordern
den Gil bedanke mich für die Runde danke
bei Ihnen zu Hause sorry dass es
technisch ein bisschen holprg war in der
letzten Viertelstunde wünsche Ihnen
trotzdem einen guten
[Musik]
Sonntag